vediamo È
verde Benvenuti su Anita Stories Io sono
Anita e io sono Vitale e oggi a
grandissima richiesta Finalmente arriva
la Challenge Slime Arcobaleno contro
Galaxy Sì lo scorso video ha raggiunto i
35.000 mis piace Grazie mille Siete
fantastici e fortissimi Wow ora vi dico
quale sarà la prossima allora sentite
bene se questo video raggiunge i
37.000 mi piace la prossima Challenge
sarà
Slime
unicorno contro Slime
sirena no la sirena la sirena sirenetta
quindi unicorno contro sirena uscirà
fantastico Quindi spolliciate
spolliciate se volete vedere la prossima
Challenge a 37.000 mi piace si
sbloccherà la prossima Challenge quindi
lasciate un bel mi piace ma oggi ci sarà
Arcobaleno contro Galaxy Io sono
Arcobaleno e vitale Galaxy siamo troppo
curiosi di vedere come usciranno Io ho
quattro ciotole separate perché sapete
che l'arcobaleno si fa in ciotole
separate anche il Galaxy si può fare in
ciotole separate ma si può fare anche
solo in una
ciotola abbiamo i vari colori qua
davanti a noi e dovremmo pescare ben
dati una volta testa alla fine del video
come sempre dovrete votare qua
nel nel sondaggio nel sondaggio se Vico
io formaggio se vinco io o se vince
Vitale in più durante il video ci sarà
la parola segreta del giorno Quindi
state attenti a guardare bene il video e
se riuscite a trovarla scrivetela Poi
nei commenti siete pronti tempo di
prendere R popcorn le patatine frutta
verdura
quci Mettetevi comodi e via Ok primo
turno siamo pronti a pescare 3 2 1
Aspetta aspetta Adesso sono preparato 3
2 1 via Eh ho toccato
questo dalla forma mi sembra un
colorante op io volevo pescare la colla
ma io non sono partito né con la colla
col colorante e cosi preso ho preso dei
glitter oro Però dai ci stanno bene il
Galax Sì infatti abbiamo iniziato un po'
strano andiamo a metterli nelle nostre
ciotole Ecco qua il mio colorante metto
il mio viola per fare la mia parte di
arcobaleno Viola e niente non c'è colla
quindi spero di pescare qualche colla
dopo altrimenti rimarrà solo il
colorante così Che bello però Wow invece
nella tua ciotola si vanno solo i
glitter Sol glitter che li mettiamo qui
eh oh che dobbiamo fare cominciamo piano
ma son carini non sono sono tipo bronzo
che belli Ok secondo turno pronti
Aspetta sì sono pronto via 3 2 1 via
uh uh mi sa che ho preso una colla
Anch'io penso dalla forma sembra una
colla la cel tu hai preso argento
glitterato ci sta ci starà benissimo per
il mio Galaxy e per Sì infatti Sarà già
super glitterato il tuo Sì c'abbiamo già
due glitter Io invece ho già il viola e
il
Spero di beccare altri colori poi
dall'arcobaleno E come fai a mettere la
colla qui nel colorante No la metto in
una ciotola diversa altrimenti diventa
Marrone Ecco qua la mia colla Celeste
che farà una parte
dell'arcobaleno bello Wow Sembra quasi
sembra quasi Galaxy anche i glitter
Verdi c'ha tanti riflessi riflessi Verdi
oroo Wow Che fortunata piace non vedo
l'ora di attivarli quindi per ora io
Celeste Verdolino perché ha un sacco di
glitter e Viola invece Vitale ha i
glitter oro e vediamo come diventano con
la colla
argento wow wow che bell'effetto sono
scappati
dappertutto Uh non vedo l'ora di vederli
mischiati Anch'io anch'io e
giriamo bene bene bene che abbiamo già
bello una bella base d'inizio qui guard
è già un
Galaxy
Che bello vagio è super brillante darci
per il terzo turno Ok terzo round 3 2 1
via ho preso qualcos'altro un'altra
colla sono an' iio penso ma non è
quella forse non è glitterata vediamo È
verde ovviamente doveva succedere la
maledizione del Verde Tu invece sì la
Viola coi glitter stupenda sarà perfetta
per il mio Galaxy diventerà un
bellissimo Galax a meno
che se presi il celeste potrebbe
mischiarsi con tutti quei colori a
uscire brutto Speriamo che PR
C Ecco qua la mia colla verde ovviamente
doveva succedere però è molto glossy Wow
È super glossy è comunque verde
verdissimo è un verde verme
u vediamo ora tuo come diventa sarà
perfetto Adesso che aggiungo questa Cola
forunato è già Galaxy del mio team
Guarda è vero Viola adesso lo andiamo a
mischiare
vediamo Wow È super
Galaxy Forse dovevo mettere un pochino
di più dai Adesso lo miglioriamo adesso
lo miglioriamo Che bello finora penso
che Vitale sia in vantaggio Perché i
colori che mi sono usciti non sono
granché pronti 3 2 1 via non so dove
mettere la mano
qua Non lo so se è una colla Sì è una ca
Anch'io ho pescato una colla
nuov vediamo che bello No vabbè ho ripes
il
verde ma scusa allora il verde no visto
che è una collo lo puoi mettere qui così
diventa tutte e tre Verdi non è
possibile la del Verde vuole che faccia
Loo Slime verde non Arc Io ho preso il
viola Io ho preso il viola Io ho preso
il viola B Allora metto un po' di verde
qua Sperando che non diventi un colore
Endo però devo per forza mettere della
colla qua altrimenti poi non si attiva e
perdo quindi SP però dai Forse sei
fortunato perché c'è tanto colorante
Viola m grigio Sì è rimasto Viola Bra St
fortunato il verde non ha vinto questa
volta Vediamo il tuo come diventa bello
pure con il viola bella Wow Sono super
belle Tra l'altro queste Colle così
glossy sia il verde che il viola davvero
stupendo wow sta diventando tutto Viola
No vabbè già Stupendo È bellissimo Ma lo
sapete che il Galaxy è il mio Slime
preferito sì lo sappiamo almeno chi ci
segue da un po' lo sa benissimo
No è diventato un bellissimo Viola
glitterato io riuscirò a fare un
arcobaleno pronti quarto quinto round
pron non ricord round quto round 3 2 1
via ho preso dei glitter No non mi dire
come non dire non dico ho preso dei
glitter No non mi dire che ho preso di
nuovo il verde Non ci posso credere all
sta forma Sì hai preso il verde Meno
male ho preso il rosa Evviva forse V tu
ince Io ho preso i glitter Rossi Beh
rosso Non è che ci stia granché bene nel
Galaxy vedremo Ok ecco qua la mia ultima
ciotola questo bellissimo Rosa
glossy Sembra una Bubble Gum sembra una
Big Bubble Wow È bellissimo una Big
Bubble Gum
bule Wow Ma quanto è bello questo colore
molto Speriamo che una volta chiati
escono di un colore decente anche se ne
dubito Qua abbiamo dei colori un po'
strani per Ess Non è vero non sono
strani sono belli
bimbo non lo so non lo so vediamo il tuo
come diventa con i glitter Rossi
mettiamo i glitter Rossi E mettiamo i
glitter Rossi
adesso
prato ma secondo me non stanno male
forse Vediamo Forse sì che sta bene e
alla fine il Galaxy si può fare con un
sacco di glitter di tutti i colori Sì è
vero sei solo invidioso perché il mio è
più bello
[Applauso]
pronti
Oh allora provate ad andare più avanti e
penso di aver preso anch'io dei glitter
perché sono in una bustina vediamo ma
sono troppo belli Uh i cuoricini ho
preso i cuoricini Arcobaleno Evviva sono
carinissimi sono super belli ma che cosa
c'entra con lo Slime arcobal perché sono
Arcobaleno vedi sono di tanti colori e
allora E tu invece io ho preso dei
bellissimi
glitter stanno super bene anche questi
Eh sì Perfetti allora ho deciso di
metterli qua nella colla trasparente
perché altrimenti negli altri non si
vedrebbero molto uh oh ma c'era anche
una stellina dentro com'è possibile è
una stella va nel Galaxi Allora scusami
eh ma è caduta lì per sbaglio ma è
grandissima quella stellina tra l'altro
No la mia paletta è sporca dall'altra Gi
prendilo con le dita ma come con le dita
devo
fischiare No io pensavo che volessi
togliere questa stellina Qui no magari
mi porta fortuna Non lo so
Uh guarda che belli
Wow questo Sembra un Mini Galaxy Slime A
me non piace sei solo invidioso No no
centra niente con il Rainbow E invece sì
guarda quanti cuoricini colorati color
Rainbow vediamo ora il tuo come diventa
mettiamo subito questi glitter blu che
sono
stupendi Wow Che belli e mischiamo Uh
sta venendo davvero bene Mi servirebbe
un pochino in più di colla però eh eh
pronti Questo è il penultimo turno
penultimo Oh dai dai dai c 3 2 1
via No ho preso un'altra colla Ci voleva
proprio anch'io ho preso unaltra colla
vediamo bello Bello Blu Eh ma forse
Quello trasforma il colore del tuo Slime
Ma no sarà stupendo Io ho preso rosso
Non so dove metter ci sta bene Secondo
me però la colla rossa la puoi mettere
qui m oppure qui così almeno ti si
attiva meglio ma ti ho dato troppo
indizi Basta ok Ho deciso di metterlo
qua perché c'è pochissima colla quindi
andiamo a mettere la nostra colla rossa
e vediamo di che colore diventerà ma
dovrebbe
mantenerlo il colore viola vediamo qua
l'hai
messa Purtroppo la mia paletta è sporca
quindi ci finiranno anche un po' di
cuoricini Ma vabbè alla fine lo farai tu
il
Galaxy Ok è rimasto il colore viola per
fortuna bene bene bene bene Vediamo il
tuo come diventa col il blu Spero che ti
rovini tutto Spero solo di non rovinarlo
vediamo con questa colla che tra l'altro
ha un colore meraviglioso Sì è
bellissimo questo blu Gloss davvero
stupendo Spero di non averne messa
troppa adesso e lo andiamo a mischiare
andiamo vediamo vediamo vediamo vediamo
vediamo vediamo vediamo Uh forse è
ancora più bello tipo Blu Notte Blu Sì è
stupendo ancora più bello di prima
ultimo round ultimo round 3 2 1
via
Oh ho toccato due
anch'io m Penso di avere dei glitter
glitter glitter glitter rosa rosa rosa
ma che colore
è Verdi è marroni Marrone è verde è
stato proprio il turno delle maledizioni
è vero Non ci posso credere Oh uscito
così bene lo Slime il marrone doveva
arrivare Uffa dobiamo a mettere i nostri
ultimi ingredienti Ecco qua i miei
glitter Verdi Quindi metti i glitter
Verdi nella parte verde Eh sì senò gli
altri me li R
anche se c'è un problema perché ora
andrò a mischiare il verde con la
paletta sporca di Viola ho preso la
paletta nuova così non sporca questo
Slime verde uh Però non è male questo
verde con questi glitter eh È molto
carino Sì come non ti piace ma secondo
me non proprio guarda perché carino non
lo so mi sembra tipo un dentifricio
verde vedremo una volta attivo Chi
vincerà perché tu sei sicuro di vincere
con queste cosette che CAI qui lo so non
lo so proprio vediamo un po' come
diventa glitter marroni Uff Adesso tocca
a me aggiungere questi glitter marroni
scuro
Uh bruttino eh Eh sì bruttino proprio
Speriamo di non
rovinarlo vediamo vediamo vediamo
Uh sembra terra
vediamo dai Forse forse è salvabile Dai
non è del tutto non è del tutto
orribile ok È arrivato il momento di
attivare i nostri Slime io lo
attivato Ma che dici No io ne dovrò
attivare quattro in quattro ciotole
diverse Vitale solo solo uno pronti 3 2
1 Ok ecco qua i miei Slime ve li faccio
vedere uno ad uno e poi li dobbiamo
mischiare Quindi questo è il primo
quello con i cuoricini Arco Baleno ed è
il più trasparente di tutti quindi non
so come andrà a fare l'arcobaleno questo
posizioni amolo qua poi abbiamo il verde
Eccolo qua anche se è verde è un
bellissimo colore acceso Quindi questo
farà un bell'effetto Arcobaleno e lo
posizioniamo già qua a
fianco poi poi abbiamo il rosa Questo è
il mio preferito perché è super glossy
super morbido sembra proprio una gomma
da masticare
masticata Comunque è morbidissimo e
andiamo a posizionarlo qua e poi per
ultimo abbiamo un altro Viola quindi
purtroppo sarebbe stato meglio avere un
altro colore diverso per fare il lo
Slime Arcobaleno ma purtroppo sono
capitati due Viola Però è molto bello
perché è metallizzato T possiamo dire
che è un arcobaleno confuso questo è un
arcobaleno con due colori uguali e Vabbè
comunque ora posizioniamo anche questo e
andiamo a mischiarli per fare
l'arcobaleno PR Però c'è da dire che non
era facile farlo da bendato Eh quindi E
sì eh Allora andiamo a mischiare il
nostro Arcobaleno vediamo un
po'
Ecco qua il nostro Arcobaleno non ha
tantissimi colori però comunque ha un
bel po' di sfumature Tada ovviamente c'è
un sacco di verde e ora Vediamo quello
di Vitale Vediamo se batte il mio
Arcobaleno il suo Galaxy
Wow che glitter Che bello altro che
glitter è molto glitterato tienti questo
cuoricino qua Guardate che bello che è
con tutti i glitter e questo colore un
po' un po' chiaro per essere un Galaxy
però dai Effettivamente sì Però dai è
bello mi
piace sentiamo un po' di
poch piccolino ancora eh però
Uh sentiamo le
bicine No non ne fa tante non scoppietta
tanto però Comunque dai Guardate che
bello questo colore blu notte ma quasi
giorno ma comunque soddisfatto non è un
colore molto forte è un colore molto
chiaro però è abbastanza chiaro Però dai
è bello Quindi
Uh è rotolato Chi vince il mio
Arcobaleno più Viola che Arcobaleno
l'arcobaleno confuso Oh il Galaxy di
Vitale votate votate votate nei commenti
Oh me lo sta inquinando Eh fammi
inquinare il mio Galaxy nel sondaggio se
vinco io o se vince Vitale Galaxy Mi
raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace E
ora vi lasciamo Qua quattro caselline su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite e
buona visione
[Musica]
Ciao
n